hi everybody time to get
okay so so today what we're going to
talk about is a topic that's
Curren resolution and I'll explain in
them just a minute what that is but
before getting onto that just a couple
of words on the announcements so the TAS
are feverishly working on getting
homework five grades worked out so we
hope that we can deliver those to you
and tomorrow just in case you're anxious
to know them before you make your final
decisions about things and then the
other thing that you should be
remembering is that the milestone for
the final project is this Tuesday now I
will confess that even to me it seems
like boy boy this milestone came around
really quickly so you probably feel that
EE I realize and so you know I do
apologize for that a little bit but
you're really our hope was that we could
actually use this to be helpful and to
give you feedback on what you're doing
and suggestions and it just really
seemed like well the only chance in
which we can kind of turn around giving
more feedback on the projects before it
goes into the final week of the quarter
is if we can kind of get stuff Tuesday
and hope to be then sort of turning it
around again by the end of the week so
the hope is to help you not to just
create obstacles and roadblocks in your
life okay so today what we're going to
do is learn more about a linguistic
topic for a change and learn some more
stuff about what goes on in coreference
resolution so first of all I'm going to
talk about the task and then go on to
some of the kinds of models that people
do for coreference resolution so first
of all what is it so the idea of
co-reference resolution is what we do
which we have a text Barack Obama
nominated Hillary Rodham Clinton as the
Secretary of State on Monday and this
text like most texts are about entities
where entities are commonly human beings
but they can be other
things like gods or talking giraffes or
whatever it is so it seems like we want
to make find where entities are
mentioned so may entities are mentioned
they're referred to as mentions so
things like Barack Obama and Secretary
of State he her they are mentions of
entities and then when we talk about
coreference resolution the tasks that
we're wanting to do is say which of
these mentions refer to the same entity
the same real thing in the world so well
one entity that's mentioned in this text
is Barack Obama and then he's referred
to later in the text as his and he and
so these three read noun phrases are
also referent to each other and that
then refers to this real-world entity
and then we have these references
Hillary Rodham Clinton Secretary of
State Hershey first lady they're all
references to a different entity and so
they all refer to this person and so
those are examples of our Co reference
in a way this is true sort of seems
obvious to a human being looking at
things but it can actually be kind of
tricky and hard so I thought we could
spend a few minutes doing interactive
working out Co reference together so
that you guys can think about it all for
a few minutes so here's part of a little
story it's a story by Shruti Rail called
the star now I confess that since this
is a CS class not a literature class I
did a little bit of helpful editing of
this text to make it shorter so I could
fit more of what was going on onto the
page but everything that is a sort of a
linguistic Tiffany is something that
comes from the original text okay so in
this text who is the first entity that's
mentioned
and our jaw okay okay so this managua
now we're let's do it forward where else
is bonaga mentioned in this text her son
right so this her not the son but this
her is a reference of an archer right
she resigned okay after that
okay so there's another she was there
another reference before that herself
right so herself is also referenced to
bonaga okay so then it's again she made
this she okay so we've done Vanaja okay
that's a good start
okay so then we've got akela okay
where's akela next referred to is akela
okay there we go
are there other references to akela
maybe not okay what's the next entity
that's mentioned proj well okay so what
other references are there deprive a
okay so here's a tricky one right so
this they I mean who does that refer to
it refers to proj wall and Akash yeah so
this they refers both the proj will and
this Akash so that's that's something
that happens in human languages this is
referred to a split antecedents where
you have one thing that they that sort
of refer
- - distributed things that came before
it
so here is one of my first sad
admissions of natural language
processing technology none of the NLP
systems that we're going to talk about
later today or in general that have been
built deal with split antecedents they
automatically lose as soon as they're
split antecedents so that's a bit sad
but that's the state of technology so
that's something we could still work to
improve but okay there's this sort of a
that's kind of half proj well okay so
there's directly progr i'll here but was
there another place early in the text
that proj will is effectively mentioned
yeah so Aquila's son is really another
mention of pride well right okay okay
any other mentions of proj what maybe
not okay did we go on okay who's the
next entity a cosh so we have a cache
here and that then again we have the her
son referring to a cache and here was a
cache okay what other what other
mentions of a cache are there okay so
there's another cache here bought him
okay there's another Akash okay then so
here okay so those are the obvious
Akash's there's sort of a tricky case
here which you could wonder what the
right treatment of is right you know
it's sort of says a cache was to be a
tree right so in some sense the tree is
a cache so really in terms of reference
in this story the reference of the tree
is the same as a cache and you could
think that means you should treat the
instances of the tree the instances here
of the tree and later on when the nicest
tree right that really that's sort of is
a cache as well that doesn't quite feel
right but this is something that comes
up in coreference right so here we have
a sort of a predictive construction with
your B and when you say when you have
sentences such as like you know my child
is the smartest kid in the class or
something like that in some sense you're
sort of saying that the smartest kid in
the class has the same reference as my
child and some systems count links over
that kind of predication and say that is
co reference whereas other ones don't
and think that that's not quite
reasonable so different things go on
okay so those those are fair number of
entities I mean so there are obviously
lots of other things that are mentioned
that sort of right so there's the local
park right that's a mention of some
entity there's the school right so
there's this the school here and so that
the school is Co referent with preschool
the preschool right here right and then
there's again this sort of tricky one of
how to treat
naughty child Lord Krishna because in
some sense proj Wells representing that
and then there are lots of other
entities that are mentioned right
there's a t-shirt and there's trousers
and things like that another tricky
thing that turns up here when you get
later on into the story is you can have
entities that have parts so we not only
have a tree but that tree then has a lot
of parts right so the tree has a trunk
and the tree has foliage and things like
that and there are these red balls that
are representing fruits right so there's
a lot of stuff that somehow connected
together and somehow separate and that's
sort of that doesn't fit terribly well
with the kind of models we use with
coreference either because really we
make our CO reference reference models
basically out of this notion of entities
but somehow this is complexity that you
know human beings have parts to right we
have hands and faces and we can say oh
that's a separate entity but there's
somehow and involved with the other
entity okay
hope that's sort of useful to give some
idea why is coreference resolution
useful so there are all kinds of things
that we'd like to do well in natural
language processing that you really
can't do well unless you know how to do
co-reference resolution so anything that
we want to do in terms of
question-answering summarization
extracting facts from text or anything
like that there are places we're going
to fail unless we can do coreference
resolution because if we're reading a
piece of text and it says he was born in
1961 we can get a fact out or answer a
question if we can work out who he was
but we probably can't otherwise there
are there's sort of another place that
where this is very useful is in machine
translation so that lots of languages
drop pronouns so you don't have to give
explicit pronouns but you need to be
able to work out
I'll fill them in and this is making
coreference decisions about arguments of
verbs and so here a couple of examples
that coloring from spanish to english so
in spanish you can freely drop the
subjects of verbs and in these sentences
in the becaus clause there's no overt
subject and so he gets Alicia alike Swan
because he's smart and so Google
Translate has stuck in a he and that is
right and to stick in that he it's
implicitly making a co-reference
decision and say okay well the subject
of this adjective smart should be Kwan
who's male and therefore I should say he
but you know the reality is Google
Translate knows nothing about
coreference and making these Co
reference decisions and as has been
covered quite a bit in the media now and
I think came up earlier in the earlier
class that Google Translate mainly just
default to male default so if you sort
of swat swip it if you flip it around
and say one likes Alicia
it also says because he's smart whereas
probably it should be because she's
smart in that case and indeed you notice
the bad effects of that everywhere so
many languages Turkish Indonesian don't
actually have gender so that they're
much less sexist languages than English
French or German is but what happens
when you then translate where you just
have a generic pronoun that means third
person pronoun that Google Translate is
essentially using this language model
which means that reconstructs the worst
of stereotypes of she is a cook and he
is an engineer he is a doctor and well
in a connected piece of discourse if
you'd like Google Translate to be able
to do better than that well again what
would be required is that you could
actually do Co reference resolution and
track along the actors in the text as
you go along
one final
example we haven't really talked about
yet but we'll get back to soon now
because the class is almost over is
doing things with dialogue agents or
chat systems that as soon as you wanting
to do anything more than a single turn
dialogue that you need to start dealing
with reference so if you've got
something like book tickets to see James
Bond then you want to say something like
spectra is playing near you at 2:00 and
3:00 today how many tickets would you
like two tickets for the showing at 3:00
that as shown in the color there are
various kinds of reference going on here
where things have related reference but
it's kind of complicated here and this
is something that we'll come back to in
a moment
so James Bond inspector and obviously
the same thing but in a context like
booking movies they are the same thing
because one is the name of a character
in a movie series and the other is the
name of a movie that's currently showing
that belongs to that so that they're
sort of associated in a sort of subtle
way that is an exact identity but it's
relevant to a lot of the things that we
want to do I'll come back to that in a
little bit when we talk a bit more about
the linguistics of this okay so if we
want to do the task of coreference
resolution there are essentially two
steps so the first step is gee we want
to work out what mentions there are in
the text that we should be doing
something with and this one is
effectively pretty easy but I'll have
just a few slides on that immediately
and then what the bulk of the class is
going to be on is working out
coreference between mentions and if you
think about this Co reference is
essentially a clustering task because if
you do the first task you have a set of
mentions and then you want to be saying
well how can i group these into clusters
that have the same reference and so
that's where we're going to look at more
at doing so quickly on mentioned
detection so um for mention we want to
find all the spans that are candidates
for referring to
entity and the answer to what these
candidates are is basically they're all
the noun phrases in the text and so
normally people think of there being
three types of mentions that we identify
there are pronouns I you he she it etc
that are referring to different entities
their explicit names of people like that
was our barack obama and hillary clinton
examples and then many of the tricky
examples and then when we have common
noun phrases like a dog or the big
fluffy cat stuck in the tree that the
big fluffy cat stuck in the tree is a
mention it's actually a complex mention
because it also has embedded inside at
other mentions so the tree is also a
mention okay so how can we detect
mentions well one answer is to say well
we've looked at various other NLP
systems on and off and we could just use
those NLP systems as pre-processing
systems to find mentions so for pronouns
there are part of speech tigers that say
what's a noun or a verb or a pronoun and
so we can run those and find all the
pronouns and we're done from for the
names of things like barack obama we've
talked a couple of times about named NT
recognizes so we can run those and find
all the named entities then for a common
noun phrases that's sort of where we
need parsers to find the structure of
the sentence and find where the noun
phrases are and we have talked about
dependency parsers and well one choice
is you can use a dependency parser to
find the sort of nominal arguments and
work with them that's sort of actually a
little bit subtler than just sort of
wanting to pick out spans that refer to
common noun phrases so the other notion
of parsing which we come back to next
weakens constituency parsing in some
sense constituency parsers are the
simplest way to find mentions for this
process most of it seems in is easy
there are sort of tricky cases as to
what counts as a mention or not so if
it's kind of it is sunny I mean
eat a mention of something it sort of
seems like it's not realized just it
seems like it's an it that you stick at
the start of the sentence that doesn't
mean anything so that's maybe not a
mention every student is every student a
mention I mean it's certainly at best
it's some kind of collective but it's
not sort of a very clear concrete
reference that goes further if I saw
have used different quantifiers there
was like every and Noah called
quantifiers I mean no student definitely
doesn't have reference because it's not
pointing at anything right it's
asserting a claim of non-existence so
that there's definitely no it isn't a
mention of anything you know the best
doughnut in the world it does that have
reference that's unclear this is the
kind of thing that actual philosophers
of language debate over right so if
there was agreement on what the best
doughnut in the world is then maybe it
has reference but I can say sentences
like I'm searching everywhere to find
the best doughnut in the world and then
in that sentence it doesn't have any
reference right it's sort of intentional
description of what I'm hoping to find
but there's no concrete thing it refers
to things like quantities a hundred
miles that sort of behaves like a noun
phrase but it's it's sort of really a
quantity that doesn't really have
reference and so then there's a question
of how can you deal with this stuff well
our tool whenever we want to deal with
stuff is we train classifiers asn't they
pick out things or dimensions and things
that are art and so that's something
that you could do is write a classifier
that filters out these spurious things
that you want to say aren't really
mentions and people absolutely have done
that but commonly actually people skip
that step and you just sort of instead
have your mentioned detector find all
candidate mentions because it turns out
that that tends to work pretty well
because after we found all of our
mentions
we're then gonna be doing this
clustering process to find Co referent
mentions and if there are just a few
stray mentions like no student and we
don't cluster them wrongly with anything
else it kind of doesn't do any harm
because we're mainly involved in this
clustering process okay um something you
might be wondering is well I've sort of
implied now we have a pipeline I'm
saying we're gonna run a part of speech
tagger and we've got a runner named
Antony recognized and we're gonna run a
parser and we're going to run a a named
a mention detector and then eventually
we're going to run this car F clustering
system so we have a sort of a five step
pipeline is that the only way you can do
Co reference resolution and the
traditional answer was yup that's the
way he did Co reference resolution that
essentially all systems for Co reference
resolution until approximately 2016 or a
pipeline that went through about those
stages but just recently an artist Scott
cover one such system later in the class
that people in the neuro world have
started doing what's been effective in a
lot of places in the neural networks
world of saying can we just build an
end-to-end CO reference system that
starts with just plain text of a
paragraph and feeds out Co reference
clusters without there being any
intervening pipeline steps and I'll show
you a bit more about how that works but
before we get into systems I just want
to say a little bit more about the
linguistics of coreference there's
actually quite a lot of interesting
stuff here and to a fair degree it's not
actually stuff that's been thought about
very much by people who build NLP
systems right I already mentioned from
the shruti rail story the example of
split antecedents right that that's just
a clear linguistic phenomenon that
happens and it's not even incredibly
rare right but you know
people build these simple machine
learning models that just can't deal
with that and there's really quite a bit
more structure to what happens in the
Linguistics of coreference it isn't
really being exploited and most of the
systems people--but build so I just want
to show people a bit more of that and
essentially to sort of understanding
more about how people see things
linguistically there are two concepts
that are related and commonly confused
that are really different so one is
coreference so we say that things are Co
referent when there are two mentions and
they refer to the same entity in the
world so if it's sort of Donald Trump
and the current president right there
two mentions and they refer to the same
person in the world and so that is a
relationship of coreference
and that's then contrasted with a nefra
and so the idea of a nefra
is some terms in text don't have
independent reference and you work out
their reference by relating them back to
another thing in the text so if we have
the sentence Barack Obama said he would
sign the bill
he is an anaphor and if I just say he
what does he refer to in the abstract
well you know apart from saying
something male right you've got no idea
right because you can't work out what he
means just by knowing he you have to be
looking at a text and interpreting it
relative to the text and then if you're
interpreting it relative to the text
you're then in this situation of okay I
see this refers back to Barack Obama so
he is another mention of Barack Obama
then and this then is this concept of a
nefra so the picture we have is sort of
like this that you can either have these
independent mentions which do refer to
the same thing in the world their Co
referent but in many cases such as when
they're full mentions like President
Obama
versus Barack Obama they don't have any
textural relationship it's just they
happen to refer to the same thing in the
world and that then contrasts with cases
like Barack Obama said he would do
something whether he has a textural
relationship back to Barack Obama and
that's an example of a nefra this might
up until now feel like an almost
meaningless distinction but something
that maybe gives you more of a sense
that there's something useful here is
these textual relationships exist even
when there isn't coreference
so we sort of mentioned before these
cases like no dancer right so no dancer
doesn't have reference right it refers
to nothing but if you have a sentence
like no dance the twisted her knee well
we have an anaphor here and that anaphor
is referring back to no dancer
despite the fact that no dancer doesn't
have reference so we can still have the
anaphoric textual relationship and
indeed you know her knee is then a part
of her and so these are these sort of
part relationships again but her knee in
the sense that I'll just come back to is
also an anaphor which is interpreted
with respect to the dancer so we have
two anaphoric relationships here even
though we have no reference there's
another interesting case of anaphoric
relationships which aren't the same as
reference which is you could have looser
forms of anaphoric relationships so you
get lots of sentences like this we went
to see a concert last night the tickets
were really expensive so we have this
mention here of the tickets and but
really to interpret the tickets we have
to interpret them with respect to this
mentioned back here a concert because
really what this is saying the tickets
for the concert we're really expensive
so this is also referred to as an
anaphoric relationship where the meaning
of the ticket
has to be interpreted texturally based
on another noun phrase but it's not a
co-reference relationship the the
concert and the tickets are clearly two
different entities so these kind of
looser cases are referred to as bridging
and ephra because you sort of have to
supply for yourself the bridge the
relation that connects together the
antecedent and the anaphor okay so
that's how we then have these pictures
that we have this sort of not in not
complete crossovers between coreference
and a nefra that we've sort of talked
about I have one other note on nefra who
has anyone here ever done any ancient
Greek any ancient Greek yes okay so from
from the origins of the words and nefra
and ephra is meant to be that you're
finding your textual reference before
you and so there's actually a
complimentary term of art which is
referred to as Katara where you're
finding your reference after you so here
is a beautiful example of Katara so this
is from Oscar Wilde's the Picture of
Dorian Gray from the corner of the divan
of persian saddle-bags on which he was
lying smoking as was his custom
innumerable cigarettes Lord Henry Wotton
could just catch the gleam of the
honey-sweet and honey-coloured blossoms
of a laburnum right so here we have this
mention Lord Henry Wotton
and there are two anaphors that refer to
Lord Henry Wotton he and his and that
they both come before Lord Henry Wotton
and so these are referred to as
instances of katha fuhrer among a
certain kind of classical scholar
and in case you don't know what a
laburnum is this is a laburnum right but
yeah so this is Katara now there are two
sad things to say
the first sad thing is in modern
linguistics the term Katara is
completely disused and we mean we just
used the word an N F ORS everywhere as
meaning a word that gets reference from
some other mention in the text and it
doesn't matter what side it's on so that
we goes downhill one stage two
linguistics
but then we get to NLP and we go
downhill a second stage because what you
will see is that in general the systems
that people are building for reference
resolution they don't make any
distinction of direction at all that
once you find a mention you're always
looking backwards for its reference and
you've got no idea that well maybe
sometimes you could look for words so
effectively what it means that the
system's end up doing is saying well
there's a he here there are various
other things there's a here's etc and
you'll eventually get the Lord Henry
Wotton and you'll be able to be trying
to find its reference by looking
backwards
even though that's sort of ill form from
any kind of linguistic sense whereas
really he and his that should have been
looking for their reference forward okay
if I'm good up till there any questions
okay we'll move ahead and try and move
on to kinds of Co reference models so I
wanted to tell you as much as I can and
I have 45 minutes left about so the kind
of models people build with Co reference
and I hope to mention quickly four
different ways that people have looked
at Co reference I want to tell you a
teeny bit about classical rule-based Co
reference then mention mentioned pick Co
reference spend the most time on mention
ranking systems which have tended to be
the easiest simple systems
and then just say a little bit about
clustering systems which should be the
right way to do it but in practice has
been a way that's been hard to get the
best performance from okay so here's a
bit of history and this guy here is
Jerry Hobbs he just had his retirement
party from University of Southern
California last month so Jerry Hobbs way
back when wrote a famous paper as in
1976 on coreference resolution and in
that paper he proposed what's normally
now referred to as the Hobbes algorithm
but actually in his paper he refers to
it as a naive algorithm and how come
back to that distinction in just a
moment but what the Hobbs algorithm was
is if you have a sentence so actually I
should say this this algorithm is just
for finding the reference of pronouns so
one can extend out to other cases but
the part I'm going to show you is just
the part for doing the reference of
pronouns so when you find out and find a
pronoun and you want to say what is it
Co referent with what you're going to do
is run this mechanical algorithm that's
looking at a part of a sentence and is
working out what to do with it begin at
the NP immediately dominating the
pronoun go up the trees of the first NP
or s call this X and the path P
traversal off it goes on and on there's
more of it that was only the beginning
of it there are a lot more stages but
you know I'm not don't really want to go
into the details of this but you know to
try and explain the flavor of it here's
a piece of text Niall Ferguson is
prolific well-paid and a snappy dresser
Steven most heated him and so if you can
remember any of the steps of that
algorithm here's our pronoun him and
then what it said to do was begin at the
NP a noun phrase above the pronoun and
then it's said to go up to the first
noun phrase or s above that here's the s
above that
and then what you're meant to do is from
there you're meant to go left to right
through stuff that came before that so
there's a lot of cleverness in this
handwritten algorithm you know this is
in the space of clever handwritten
algorithms and so what this is
reflecting is that you might just think
you should go to the closest thing to
find reference but actually if you have
reference within the same sentence it's
much more common for the sort of highest
syntactic roles to be what your co
referent with so you're more likely to
be Co referent with a subject and an
object and you're more likely to be Co
referent with an object than something
like a noun phrase you know that's
inside a prepositional phrase that
follows the object so we're going to
start from the left here and we're going
to say here's a noun phrase Steven Maus
that's the first one we come to and then
there's this clever bit of text that
says traversal branches below X that are
to the left left to right proposes
antecedent a noun phrase that has a noun
phrase or sentence between it an act in
the S so it was saying this will be a
candidate if and only if there's some
other noun phrase or s in between and so
what that's saying is Steven Maus hated
him it hit this him cannot refer back to
Steven Maus and that's sort of pretty
much a fact of English syntax but what
is wanting to do is distinguish between
another thing that we could have had
here was a noun phrase that had another
possessive noun phrase inside it so if
we had something like Steven Moss's
mother hated him right then for Steven
Moffat Moss's mother hated him then that
would in that case it'd be perfectly
okay for him to be Co referent with
Steven Maus and the algorithm allows
that because relative to this noun
phrase there's another noun phrase above
in between okay so that didn't work as
an antecedent antecedent so then we go
on to the next step of the algorithm and
then the next step says we should
proceed backwards through preceding
sentences right to left and so that
captures an important heuristic that
proximity is actually a good heuristic
to find Co reference because Co
reference for pronouns is usually close
by overall and so we go to the first
sentence back and then in this sentence
again we go into within the sentence go
left to right because there's the same
kind of subject prominence role and so
we're going to start in this sentence
and we're going to say okay here's a
noun phrase and now because we're in a
different sentence there's nothing wrong
with this one
so we say aha we have a candidate Niall
Ferguson is a possible antecedent and
it's the first one we found and
therefore we say that him refers back to
Niall Ferguson and this algorithm
actually gives the right answer if you
could follow along all of that though
that sounds like horrible handwritten
stuff but so Jerry Hobbs was aware of
that this was horrible handwritten stuff
but he was interest in this algorithm
for a couple of reasons
I mean reason one is you know this is
actually one of the first places in
natural language processing that someone
produced the base line right in for
final projects and elsewhere and stuff
we gave you right it's seen now in NOP
and other areas that anything you're
doing the first thing you should do is
have a baseline a simple system and see
how well it works and this was his
simple rule-based system for doing
coreference and he wanted to observe
that actually this baseline was pretty
good it actually gave the right answer a
lot of the time and so the challenge was
how to build a system that did better
than this baseline and so he was well
aware
you know it was a dumb algorithm but he
proposed it as a good baseline for doing
coreference resolution so what he was
interested in remember that we're back
in the 1970s here was how to do
knowledge-based pronominal coreference
resolution and so essentially what he
was noticing is well these kind of
syntactic factors that I was mentioning
prefer subjects prefer close by etc
they're all useful predictors but there
are lots of cases where they don't give
the right answer and to know when they
give went to know what's really the co
referent thing you have to actually
understand what's being described in the
world so if I have this sentence she
poured water from the pitcher into the
cup until it was full what is it Co
referent with a cup thank you okay so
that it refers to the cup but then let's
look at this example
she poured water from the pitcher into
the cup until it was empty what does it
refer to the pitcher okay so the crucial
thing to notice in these two sentences
is these sentences have identical
syntactic structure right so Gerry
Hobbes's algorithm can't possibly work
for both of these sentences it's going
to work for one of them but not the
other one since it's working from left
to right within a sentence it's going to
say the pitcher both times actually
right so you can't get the answer right
by Gerry Hobbes's algorithm and Gerry
believed and still believes that the
only way to get these kind of examples
right is actually if you understand the
world and you actually know what's going
on in the world so you can see what what
this is talking about and there are lots
of examples like this this is another
very famous example the City Council
refused the women a permit because they
feared violence and who does that they
refer to the city councilors
but here's another sentence the City
Council refused the women a permit
because they advocated violence who does
that they refer to the women okay so
this time it first to the women and
again you know exact extractor it
couldn't possibly be gone right by the
Hobbs algorithm so this particular pair
of examples comes from Terry Winograd
our longtime so Terry Winograd was
originally an NLP faculty he sort of got
disillusioned with NLP because there
wasn't making much progress and ventured
off into the land of HCI that became his
career but in his early work
he was interest in these phenomena and
came up with this example and so this
example really stuck with people and so
these kind of contrasts are referred to
by other people as Winograd sentences or
Winograd schemer and so this is actually
something that interest in is revived
recently so Hector Lou Levesque wrote a
paper yes five years ago now where he
was trying to advocate for a return to
doing more in the way of knowledge and
world modeling and artificial
intelligence and arguing that there are
lots of problems that you just can't
solve by the kind of crude statistical
methods that our machine learning
systems are using and that you really
needed to do more world understanding
and so he proposed that these Winograd
schema would be a good alternative to
the Turing test as a way of measuring
intelligence and actually they're just
co-reference decisions right so so
there's sort of a claim here that if you
can do a CO reference right a hundred
percent of a time you've solved
artificial intelligence in the jus so
that you can conclude knowledge of the
world in two coreference problems yeah
so people have then tried to work on
these Winograd schemas and lévesque
feeling was you know you just couldn't
do these using kind of the kind of
statistical factors that people put into
their machine learning
systems he was partly wrong about that
because subsequent work both neural
systems and otherwise has shown that
actually you can get a non-trivial
distance with these kind of problems
because you know if it is the case that
you know you can somehow see enough
examples where the City Council refuses
permits fearing violence you know if
you've got if you're collecting your
neural language model over tens of
billions of words you might have seen
some instances of things like that and
you could sort of predictor just on
statistical patterning but the question
is you know how far can you actually get
doing that without having a bit more of
a world model and so that was you know
what Hobbes was interested in way back
in 1978 so he wrote the naive approach
is quite good computationally speaking
it will be a long time before a
semantically based algorithm is
sophisticated enough to perform as well
and these results set a very high
standard for any other approach to aim
for he was totally right about that that
it really wasn't until the 2010 that
anybody managed to produce an algorithm
for pronominal and after a resolution
that outperformed the hobbs algorithm
even though it was just what he called a
naive algorithm or he might call a crude
set of linguistic rules but he says yet
there is every reason to pursue a
semantically based approach the naive
algorithm does not work anyone can think
of examples where it fails in these
cases it not only fails it gives no
indication that has failed and offers no
help in finding the real antecedent so
food for thought there but
notwithstanding that I'm going to just
rush ahead at this point and tell you
about some of the statistical and neural
algorithms that have been used for
coreference resolution so the simplest
form of algorithm is commonly used is
what is called mentioned peer models so
what we mean by mentioned peer models is
we are going to take pairs
mentions and we're going to train a
binary classifier that says is Co
referent or isn't Co referent and so
then we're going to proceed left to
right through the text and every time we
get to a new mention we're going to then
evaluate our classifier with respect to
every preceding mention and we're going
to say are they Co referent and it's
gonna say yes or no and we're going to
find out that some of them it says yes
for I voted for Nader because he was
like most aligned with my value she said
if we have a good classifier it'll say
yes to the to beaut blue ones and not to
the rest of them and so then we'll have
a training time negative examples that
need own he are negative examples so if
you have data marked for Co reference we
have these sort of positive and negative
examples and we can train a model and so
for training a model we have a sort of
the classifier outcome is one or zero
based on whether two mentions a co
referent we go and have a co reference
model that predicts the probability of
them being Co referent and we're going
to train it with the same kind of
cross-entropy loss we've used other
places and try and learn a model that
predicts coreference and so then when we
get to test time and we have a piece of
text with mentions we're going to run
this classifier and it's going to say
yes or no with some probability and if
we pick a threshold like 0.5 we'll add
certain Co reference links and that sort
of looks pretty good
but we're going to sort of complete it
off by saying well if a is Co referent
to b and b is co referent to C and
really also a is co referent to C so
we're going to do a transitive closure
and that will give us our clustering
note here that there's a sir
danger in this because this means if we
make since we're with the transitive
closure that's always adding clustering
links and so that means the danger is
that we're going to over cluster because
if we make a single mistake and we link
things that should be kept separate so
for example if we wrongly said he and my
echo referent then everything in this
discourse would collapse together into
one cluster and everything would be
deemed Co referent okay and this
something that I haven't really
emphasized but comes up is well there
are some mentions that are Co referent
to nothing right in the true derail
story there was a park which was just
mentioned once in the text and so and in
this form of algorithm what we'd like
the classifier to say is no no no no no
for all of the decisions and so it's
deemed Co referent to nothing and then
it's just a single to mention this sort
of works but it hasn't proven to be the
best way of doing Co reference and a lot
of the reason why it's not the best way
to do Co reference is because we have
this phenomenon of an afro where we have
textual dependence a lot of the time it
seems that we're not really what sort of
wanting to make this all co reference
decisions we'd like to make the anaphora
decisions of textual dependence so we'd
like to say that he is dependent on NIDA
and my is dependent on I these are
anaphora relationships so we'd like to
just choose one example of what is this
an F relationship and so that's led to
people then looking at what are called
mentioned peer models right that the
problem is that if we have a long
document with lots of mentions that we
want to not be saying trying to find all
of them and say yes we just want to be
safe
there's a particular we just want to be
saying that there's a particular one so
for the here at the end here it's an at4
relationship is back to nadir and you
don't want to be trying to say this he
is also Co referent back to all of these
other things that are earlier in the
text so it's not something that's been
explored much but arguably this is a
case again where you should be
separating coreference from anaphors
because for any fours it seems like the
right way to think is that they have one
try a thing in the text that they're
textually dependent on whereas trucco
reference when you just have various
mentions in a text of Ralph Nader this
Ralph Nader that needed it that that
those aren't textually dependent and
they should all be being grouped
together as Co reference but our models
sort of don't normally try and do some
one way and some the other way but you
choose one of the models so in the other
one we do it for to do the other way you
do what's mention rankings so for
mention ranking the idea is for each
mention we're going to fight try and
find at an antecedent that comes before
before it in the text that is that it is
Co referent with and we're going to make
a one of indecision so that when we see
she here we're going to say okay what is
this co referent with and we're going to
pick one thing that's co-reference with
even though there might be others in the
text so if we're doing that we then have
a problem with singleton mentions
because if we're trying to for every
mention we find say choose the thing
that came before it in the text with
which it's Co referent the right answer
might be that there's no such thing so
what we do is we add one additional
dummy mention right at the front here
the na mentioned so one choice is you're
going to say there isn't anything
preceding
so effectively when you get to I since
this is the first real mention the text
you're necessarily going to choose as
its antecedent na you then go on to NIDA
and you have two choices you could
either say it's Co referent to AI or its
current to na ie it's a new mention a
new entity that's being mentioned in the
text and the right answer is it's a new
mention in a new entity being mentioned
in the text and then you get to he and
now you have three choices and you the
right thing is to say that's Co referent
anaida okay so this time it's for
training our models it's sort of the
same
apart from this sort of this different
one of semantics so now previously we
wanted to say that for our mentioned
peer classifier that it's going to try
and classify I and she and my and she
and both of them had to get a high score
where now it's sufficient that just one
of them gets a high score because that's
sort of enough for us to do so what
we're going to use is our good old soft
Max and so for XI we're going to put a
soft Max over the antecedents and now
Hope is simply that we get a high
probability with one of the antecedents
if it has an antecedent or a high score
with na if it doesn't have any prior
reference and so then when we're doing
classification at run time we're going
to sort of add only the highest-scoring
coreference link so that means we train
it just slightly differently because now
what we're going to do is that when we
what we're wanting to say is we want a
high score of coreference between at
least one of the antecedents and so one
possible model is we can maximize this
probability so for the ones that are Co
referent in the gold standard data we
want the sum of their assigned
probabilities to be high
and so what that means is that it's sort
of sufficient if we have one of them
giving a high probability and they don't
all have to give a high probability so
providing it's giving point nine
probabilities say to one of the correct
antecedents we're getting a high score
okay so we're going to turn that into a
loss function in the kind of standard
way we do in which we take log
probabilities and then we want to four
negative log probabilities to give us a
loss and then we're wanting to minimize
that loss so with a mention ranking
model at test time it's pretty much the
same but our softmax classifier is just
going to assign one antecedent for each
mention and so we can gonna hope that
those sort of give us the kind of
clusters that we want and there's no
subsequent clustering phase so there's a
big part of this that I left out which
was I've just said okay we had this
probability of MI in MJ as the are they
Co referent but I've sort of said zero
as to how you can determine whether
they're Co referent or not so briefly
here's the classical way of doing it the
classical way of doing it is you had a
whole bunch of features and you had a
feature based statistical classifier
which gave a score and these are the
kind of features you could use so there
are sort of strong features of person
number gender agreement so if you have a
masculine or feminine pronoun you want
to find an appropriate antecedent for it
there are weaker semantic compatibility
features so the mining conglomerate the
company the conglomerate might be sort
of similar to a company you can use
something like word to vex similarity
and assess that there are syntactic
constraints so this is then kind of like
what Hobbes says algorithm was all about
as working out how likely a different
syntactic configuration is going to mean
co-reference
and indeed is the case you know that a
lot of these feature based systems used
Hobbs algorithm as a feature inside the
system there was weighted and was
normally a very strong feature to side
co-reference there are lots of other
things you can put in as features
recency so John went to a movie Jack
went as well he was not busy the most
likely referent for he is the closer
candidate Jack I mentioned subjects are
more likely to be the antecedent john
went to a movie with Jack he was not
busy John seems a more likely and to see
that so that's the subject preference
there's also parallelism preference so
John went with Jack to a movie Joe went
with him to a bar I think a sort of
reasonable to think that him there is
probably Jack and that sort of a
parallelism reasons as opposed to going
with the subject so there are various
kind of linguistic features and
constraints and so on and you can throw
these all into a statistical classifier
and that's sort of 2000s decade correct
systems as to how they were built more
recently people have built neural
systems and so for these we're kind of
normally using the same kind of
embeddings so we'll have a candidate
antecedent that all have embeddings will
have a mention that has embeddings and
this will be something like average word
vectors or something like that for the
mentioned and we're going to feed these
into a neural network that'll give us
our score but what you find is that most
of these systems as well as having
something like word vectors they also
have additional features and these
features still capture some of the
things that were in the feature based
statistical classifiers so there will be
often features that reflect things like
what grammatical relation does this
mention have is that a subject isn't an
object that's something you could put
into the features of a mention but then
closer things are more likely to be Co
referent so you might have additional
features here which record how far apart
the mentions are and those
things get thrown in as well and so
these kind of features are still
important even in neural systems and so
I'll skip ahead now and show you a bit
about what is the kind of current state
of the art for coreference resolution
and this was a system that was done at
the University of Washington in 2017 by
Kenton Lee and assorted other authors so
the goal here was to produce and into n
Co reference system that was text in
mentioned clusters that are Co referent
out and so they're wanting to use the
Silva more complex neural network that
can do the whole thing in twin so I'll
go through the steps of that so the
first step is we just start off with
words and so for each word we're going
to look up a word embedding for it and
as another stuff we've seen we're also
going to put in a character level CNN
and the two of those concatenate it are
going to give the representation of each
token that much should look familiar
okay then after that we're going to run
a deep bi-directional LS TM back and
forth across the sentence again that
should look familiar from stuff that
we've seen before the next step gets us
a bit into doing something more special
for Co reference so what they want to do
after that is have a representation for
spans and so by span we mean any
contiguous sub phrase of the word of the
sentence so this is a span this is a
span and this is a span Electric said
the postal is a span every subsequence
so I'll come back to that but you know
they'll in principle you're working this
out for every subsequence so for every
subsequence they want to come up with
the span representation and so this span
representation is going to be in three
parts
to represent one of these sub sequences
so each of these will get its own
representation and so the question is
what and so we have this span
representation and it's going to be in
these three parts here so what these
parts are is well first of all we're
going to have a representation which is
just looking at the first word of the
span and the last word of the span
according to the BIOS DM so if we're
looking at the span the Postal Service
we're going to take this bio STM and
this bio STM and use them as part of the
representation of the span and that's a
good start
but then they actually do something a
little tricky so kind of like when we're
doing dependency parsing the idea was
well phrases are going to have a head
word so that if it's you know my younger
sister that the head word of that is
sister and there if it's something like
the goat in the corner of the field the
head word of that is going to be goat so
they want to find a way of capturing
head words out of the text and so what
they're going to do for that is use
attention so they're going to say we
have this span the Postal Service and
we're going to use attention as a span
internal mechanism just sort of
approximate ahead so what we're going to
do yeah what we going to do is we're
going to want to learn attention weights
here what we're going to do is for this
span we're going to be learning based on
the hope the ends of the span which
words to pay how much attention to so
we're going to put attention weights on
the different words and then we're going
to in the usual attention way make this
weighted sum of having put the word
pitted by directional stem peers through
a feed-forward Network
and end up with this new representation
of a weighted representation and the
hope is that in this case most of the
weight will go on this final service
which will be the head word but it'll be
sort of distributed across it and so
that gives them a model of sort of
mentions that use both ends and hope to
find the key word of the mention okay so
that's two-thirds of the span but they
still have over here this additional
features and so they still have some
additional features they want to be able
to mark speakers and addresses they want
to mark other things like the
grammatical role and which things occur
if you know that you still useful to
have some additional features and so
what they do is this is a representation
of each span and then they're going to
want to say are two spans Co referent
and so they're going to have one score
for the to two speech of two spans which
is essentially saying is that a good
mention and then you're going to have
scores of do they look Co referent and
so having calculated these
representations for each span you're
running three through things so a fully
connected feed-forward network
multiplying by weight vector and that's
giving you a is it a good mention score
and then four are they Co referent
you're taking two spans the point-wise
Hadamard product of two spans and some
extra features like distance apart in
the text and putting them through
another neural network and that's then
giving you these two spans Co referent
but all of these pieces give you an
overall loss function so you can say
that your model is okay we're going to
run these LST M's we're going to take
all spans we're going to score this and
we know the goal dance for our Co
reference system and so we want to be
predicting things that our co referent
and have a loss based on the probability
that we
calculate with these scores as a
mentioned ranking model using a soft
neck Schloss like before so if you put
all of this together and train it into
end you've got a whole current system
that goes from words to coreference
decisions there's a huge problem with
that which is if you actually applied
this naively well the problem is the
number of spans in a piece of text is
the square of the length of the text in
words and so therefore if you're making
coreference decisions which are between
pairs of spans you've then got an
algorithm that's o o T to the fourth
where the length of the text is T words
so that's sort of really really
computationally impractical so at this
point they sort of say well actually we
do want to use our mouse a little and we
want to work out how likely different
things are to be mentions so effectively
then they're putting in a lot of pruning
decide which spans are actually things
that they want to consider in their
model and so at this point in some sense
is a little bit of a cheat right because
really this pruning step here is okay
we're going to stick in mention
detection module just like a
conventional system but the prettiness
of it is in terms of the algorithm in
terms of the loss function that's
defined the loss function is really
defined in to win from just sequence of
tokens through to the mention making
decisions and so it isn't into in model
even though in practice to make it
practical you have to have something
like a mention detector to get it to
work okay pause for breath yeah so
there's one last so we've done sort of
mentioned peer model and mention ranking
model and so for both of those you're
just taking individual mentions and
saying here's another mention
what what shall I do with it let's look
at mentions and see if we're Co referent
to each other and that there's no real
concept of entities which are clusters
of mentions you're just making these
sort of one-off decisions between pairs
of mentions and somehow sort of the
entities as clusters just emerge as a
consequence of those mentioned peer
decisions so there's been this sort of
long-standing feeling that all that
can't really be right the right way to
do Co reference must be really to do it
as a clustering task and people often
refer to this as saying we want entities
as first-class citizens so we want to be
sort of putting together mentions into
clusters that represent the entities and
the obvious way to do that is to do a
kind of bottom-up a kilometre of
clustering so you start off by saying
each mention as its own singleton
cluster and then you're making decisions
to merge Clapp clusters which is
initially saying to mentions a co
referent but as you go on with it
you're then making decisions the two
clusters are Co referent or nod so the
idea here is you'll have a piece of text
google recently bla bla bla bla the
company announced Google possible a blur
the product features blue bubble blur
and so you have here some mentions and
so what you're going to do is start off
saying that okay there are these four
mentions that each their own cluster and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to make some decisions so we might
decide that these two clusters are Co
referent and merge them into one cluster
and then we might decide that these two
clusters a co referent and merge them
into one cluster and so we progressively
clustering and so then we're going to
look at these two clusters cluster 1 and
cluster 2 and say no we don't think
those ones are
and therefore we're going to keep them
apart and so your your cur efference
algorithm stops when there's nothing
left emerge and the reason why people
think that this is the right thing to do
is the feeling is that if we sort of
build partial clusters like this that
you'll be able to do a better job
because if I just sort of say well here
are two mentions Google and Google Plus
should they be regarded as Co referent
or not well since you're smart human
beings and know what Google is know what
Google+ is of course you'll answer no of
course not but you know if you're just a
computer trying to make a decision it's
so hard to know the right answer because
there are lots of other cases when there
are shortenings where the right answer
is that there co referent right because
if this had been Google and Google Corp
then it would have been right to regard
them as Co referee and or if it was sort
of something like Hillary Clinton and
Hillary it would have been right to
regard them as career friend so it can
often be kind of hard to tell what's
co-reference
but the hope is that if you've made some
of the easy decisions first so you've
decided Google and the company Ocoee
Efrain and Google+ and the product a
career and then it should be much easier
to tell and say well product and company
they're definitely different things and
therefore we should keep these things
separate and so that is the goal and so
to follow that goal the kind of models
people build and this was actually a
model that Kevin Clarke is run the PhD
students here and we did a couple of
years ago the idea as well what we're
going to do is we're initially going to
consider mention peers and build some
kind of distributed mentioned peer
representation which is kind of similar
to what we were doing previously with
the previous models but we're then going
to go beyond that and come up with
cluster representations and then we can
look at cluster peer representations and
we would hope that by looking at
these cluster representations will be
able to make better decisions of what to
merge or what next emerge I have a few
more slides that go through the clock
and many algorithm but I also have just
a few minutes left and so I think I'll
skip the details you know I think the
main thing that's interesting here is
the idea of clustering based coreference
algorithms and why in principle it
should give you extra oomph and that's
sort of the main useful thing to get
through that's what I want to make sure
we have covered in the last few minutes
that I've said nothing at all about is
how do you evaluate co-reference
resolution and how well does it work so
let me skip ahead to that so if you look
at coreference
resolution papers or something like that
there are many metrics that people have
used to evaluate coreference
and they have a long alphabet soup of
names so there's muck and SI phan le a
and b cubed and Blanc and things like
that
so effectively part of it is that if you
look in the clustering literature there
are lots of ways that people try and
evaluate clustering and essentially any
of those metrics and some other ones you
can port over 200 references on I mean Y
it's kind of difficulties though the
situation you have is that you have a
gold standard which picks out certain
clusters and the system picks out
certain clusters and you get some result
like this and you have to decide how
good it is so I'm going to show you just
quickly one particular algorithm so the
B cubed algorithm uses precision and
recall and f-measure like we thought of
before so it looks at a cluster
identified by the system and it says
well this cluster is 4/5 gold cluster
one so the precision is 4/5 but actually
there are six things in gold cluster
so it only has a recall of four six of
that cluster and then it similarly does
for the other one the same kind of
calculation and then it's going to
average across the Precision's and
recalls and it's going to come up with
an overall B cubed score in if you think
about this from an algorithms
perspective this is actually tricky
because I sort of said okay this cluster
is mainly gold cluster one so use that
as its reference but that means you have
to do a bipartite graph alignment
between system clusters and gold
clusters so hidden and hidden inside
this evaluation system is actually an
np-complete problem but in practice you
can normally do it heuristic aliy well
enough then the evaluation method runs
and works okay and so the kind of thing
to notice is that if you under cluster
you automatically get great precision
but you get bad recall and if you over
cluster you get get great recall because
everything that should be in the same
cluster is but you get terrible
precision and so what you want to be
doing is balancing those two things okay
last two minutes just to give you some
idea of performance so these are results
from the on two nodes data set which is
about three thousand documents
chinese-english labeled for coreference
the scores I'm reporting is actually an
average over three metrics one of which
is the one I just showed you for be
cubed here are some numbers so Liat al
2010 was a stanford system so that there
was this shared task evaluation of
coreference systems and we believe that
Jerry Hobbs was still right and you
could do fine with rule-based
co-reference
and so in 2010 we managed to beat all
machine learning systems with a
rule-based coreference system and we
were proud of it and that's its
performance right here
in subsequent years people did start to
do a bit better with with machine
learning systems but as you see not very
much right for these 2012 systems there
this one's somewhat better this one
really wasn't better this than making a
bit of progress starting in 2015 there
started to be neural systems so Wiseman
was a tower saw the first neural system
I vaguely mentioned this Clarke and
Manning system and the numbers are going
up into the mid-60s and this is the
Kenton Lee system that as the end when
you're co-reference
and on English a skiing about 67 so
something you'll notice from this is the
numbers aren't great so coreference is
still far from a solved problem so if
you want to have a bit of fun and you
can go out and try co-reference systems
for yourself
there's Stanford one on the first link
or the one from hugging face is a good
modern coreference system as well and if
you just try this out some some pieces
of text you'll notice they still get
lots of things wrong so there's still
more work to do cuz this is just a
harder language understanding tasks
which is just kind of like Jerry Hobson
Terry Terry Winograd earlier observed
okay but I'll stop the end for now
thanks light oh yeah I should have
reminder invited speaker next Tuesday so
be taking attendance for adviser
speakers